[موسيقى]
يشرح القائمون على اداره مخيم الهول خريطه
اقسامه قبل جوله الاستكشاف الوضع داخله
لكنهم يقولون انما نراه هنا غير كامل
واعداد قاطني المخيم غير دقيقه فهناك
حالات زواج غير موثقه ومواليد جدد
يتفاجئون بوجودهم في خيم الاجنبيات كلما
شنوا عمليات مداهمه وهي خيم يفترض انها
تضم نساء الدواعش واطفالهن فقط فالازواج
اما في السجون او قتله تصريح مفاجئ بدا
انه يحتاج شرحا
لنفهم القصه توجهنا الى دلبرين كوباني
القياديه في وحده حمايه المراه في اقليم
الجزيره وهي كانت اشرفت على حمله
الانسانيه والامر التي شنتها القوات
الامنيه ضد خلايا داعش في الهول
يجب ان يكون قسم الاجنبيات في المخيم دون
رجال اثناء العمليه اكتشفنا انهم اخفوا
المراهقين الذكور في الانفاق التي حفروها
كانوا يفعلون ذلك حتى لا تتمكن قوات الامن
من اكتشافهم انهم يستخدمون هؤلاء
المراهقين لاغراض الانجاب
هناك لاجئون عراقيون وبعض النازحين
السوريين يذهبون خلصتا الى قسم الاجانب
للزواج من اجنبيات انهم يستخدمون كل هذه
الطرق لانجاب المزيد من الاطفال
[موسيقى]
غادرنا قسم الاجنبيات واتجهنا لاقسام
السوريين والعراقيين وهي مخصصه لداعشيات
سوريات وعراقيات كما تضم نساء وازواجهن
نزحوا من مناطق السيطره داعش وهؤلاء
يقولون المسؤولون عن الامن هنا انه يصعب
الجزم بعدم ارتباطهم بالتنظيم سابقا او
بخلاياه داخل المخيم حاليا
هذا ناصح سوري يروي بعض ما يجري داخل
المخيم
سمعت
اكثر من اربعه يعني
سمعت انه تزوجوا كثير لماذا حتى في واحد
معنا مطلوب وخربان منهم
قائلين لزوجته تخلعيه
يعني
يجعل اعداد المواليد شهريا اكبر من
المتوقع
[موسيقى]
عدد الولادات هي كثيره جدا يعني بالشهر
بالشهر اللي فات كان عنا 61 حاله ولاده
باقسام العراقيين فقط
[موسيقى]
جيل جديد باعداد كبيره ينشا في خيم
الدواعش في الهول على الغالب يحاول
التنظيم بهذا ضمان استمراريته وتعقيد مهمه
محاربته صار بن عيشوبات العربيه الحسكه
[موسيقى]